i think about being
a woman a mother a tech ceo
in uh you know the enterprise software
space
and yeah i i do think i'm i'm probably
unique
in that industry in terms of my
background
but i do believe that different
perspectives are good and i think as
long as we
keep different perspectives at the table
and we keep an open dialogue and
everyone's
listening into each other and talking
we're going to make great decisions and
i'm excited to to kind of bring my
perspective and my style
to the industry
so i joined vimeo about six years ago
as a director of marketing and three
years ago i was promoted to ceo
to help pivot the platform from being a
viewing destination that competed with
youtube
to being a software platform for
businesses
i definitely was younger less
experienced and just generally at a very
different background
than sort of what's traditional i
recognized
that and i tried to use it as an
advantage and i do really believe that
the best decisions get made
when you have different perspectives in
the room and so the way i kind of
approached it i remember every time i
walked into a boardroom
i i was you know i looked very different
than everybody else around me
but i actually thought of it as that
means that it's actually incumbent upon
me
to be vocal because that's the only way
we will collectively make better
decisions
so i had a very sort of maybe
stereotypical
kind of immigrant experience i grew up
in flint michigan
in a very tight-knit community of other
indian families
and my dad's a physician but his true
passion is entrepreneurship
and he raised me to believe that the
best way you can impact your community
is by creating jobs i think all of that
created in me at a very young age a
desire to be in business to be a leader
to build things and to have an impact on
a community
if you'd asked like little ambitious
anjali what she wanted to be
i would have said i wanted to be a ceo
or a leader of a platform
that i thought was affecting positive
change
and it's honestly amazing to me that i
feel like i'm actually in that position
now i feel so privileged and fortunate
but i do feel in some ways like
my parents like american dream has kind
of come true for me
i think being a mother has made me
both stronger and more empathetic
i look at each of my my colleagues and
it's like i didn't appreciate what was
happening in their personal lives and
how hard it can be and there were so
many things about the way that we work
in the past that i just were so
insensitive
to working parents that i never
appreciated i mean i was the one
before i had a kid who was like why
aren't we doing the six o'clock call
you know without realizing that's the
window for a lot of people to see their
kids
so i think it's been obviously an
incredible experience my very proud
mother
but i also just think you know it's it's
it's a challenging one
and if you can survive it makes you
stronger and i i do think it's
the job of folks like me and and other
leaders to make
it easier for working parents to
to really do all the things that they
can do
some of the lessons that i learned from
my experience and becoming a ceo
is look where others aren't looking
sometimes when you're in organizations
it feels like there aren't opportunities
and you have to create your own
opportunities and sometimes the best way
to do that
is to find the places where people
aren't focused
don't stay in your lane i think
sometimes as an employee you feel like
the organization just wants you
to do x y and z but actually i can tell
you as a ceo
i want to grow the business and do
what's great for the business and if
there are people around me
who can bring ideas to help me grow the
business
i want to hear them i want to learn
i want to build and i want to make an
impact and today
i'm more excited than ever to do that at
vimeo i think we have an incredible
platform and opportunity
um and i'm also you know i got a lot of
energy
and a lot of work um and value i want to
bring to the world so
i hope to do many things but always if
i'm learning building and making an
impact
[Music]